ladies and gentlemen welcome to the Tim
Dillon show uh what are what's everybody
mad that Obama came out
so why is that a why is it a big deal
that he came out I think it's uh right
the little twink from stranger things
came out and then they're uh honoring
him we'll get to that later and but but
I'm I'm happy that everyone comes out
why are people mad that the president of
the United States
uh came out of the closet
what's the big deal
you don't know everything about these
people and it's kind of nice to learn
things about them as you go
I mean I think that's kind of cool to
like
you know you don't know everything about
all these relationships
there you know they're mysterious
and Barack Obama wrote to an ax
in a letter
I make love to men daily but in the
imagination
yeah I mean
is that such a big deal
that he's having gay sex fantasies
in his imagination and yet none in real
life ever
even if you're the president you can't
arrange a tryst
with a guy that you might then later
drown
um what's wrong with it what's the big
uh deal
the more than 40 year old letter to an
ex-girlfriend recently resurfaced after
Obama biographer David Garrow gave a
long and winding interview
on the one time commander-in-chief
in regard to homosexuality I must say
that I believe this is an attempt to
remove oneself from the present
a refusal perhaps to perpetuate the
endless farce of Earthly life
you see I make love to men daily but in
the imagination
Obama 21
wrote to Alex McNair
in November of 1982.
that's when he was Barry he further
wrote my mind is androgynous to a great
extent
and I hope to make it more so until I
can think in terms of people not women
as opposed to men but in returning to
the body
this is what if you want to have fun you
drive through a Del Taco and when they
say are you ready you just read this
letter and you go
I see that I have been made a man and
physically in life I choose to accept
that contingency
he added
McNair who dated Obama during his year
at Occidental College in LA
later redacted the salacious paragraphs
which the Pulitzer prize-winning
historian Carol hunted down and included
in his Tome Rising Star
well I don't know I don't know what any
of that it's a guy who's trying to
impress a girl
by telling her he's uh he's trying to be
uh conceptual and he's talking about the
masculine and The Feminine and he's also
saying that he has sex with man or makes
love to them
in his imagination I don't know
uh if if that is uh coming out of the
closet it's not not coming out of the
closet right it's it's something there I
I don't think he's addressed it
I don't think he said anything about it
it just the text stands as is
we support him
we support him and
that's really what it comes down to I
have nothing but good things to say
um about his decision
uh which isn't his decision but his
biographer's decision
to include this uh lovely
note
about his predilection for having
homosexual fantasies which a lot of
people probably have
but that's a thing you don't know like
for example Bill Clinton cheated on his
wife
you know remember
he cheated Bill Clinton on his wife
and I mean she was a a beautiful lovely
woman why but he cheated on her
um President George H.W bush like
President Bush's wife Laura Bush killed
someone with her car well we don't we
don't we don't know much about that we
barely talk about it because it's not
that big of a deal
you know George W bush wasn't really
like uh the Bush family did a great job
convincing you that they were like Hard
Scrabble Texas Ranchers but they were
preppy uh New England wasps
but they felt that it would be a better
sell if they were Hard Scrabble like W's
like a Rancher he's in Crawford he's
clearing brush
you know that was all fake
and maybe Obama's gay we don't know
we don't know a lot about these people
they just rule us
it's not our business all the time uh
you know they're mysterious his name was
Barry
Barry cetera
now he's Barack Obama right isn't that
his name that was his name
so
you know
the one guy who became the president
that we knew the much about that we knew
the most about
the one guy that we knew the most about
like he was in the news for 40 years
before he became president was the game
show host who said I want to have sex
with my daughter
but that's the one we knew we vetted him
that was Trump we vetted him we knew him
he was a wrestling heel
you know he had feuds with fat people on
The View
we knew him the rest of these people we
don't know them we don't know them at
all and then there we retroactively get
to know them because somehow whenever
they get into the public eye there's
like 12 biographies of them that are
ready to go just ready to drop and
there's all of these biographies that
they all supposedly they had all this
time to write these biographies and run
for president and be a senator and there
and then we get to know these people
retroactively they reverse engineer who
they are after they are already in our
consciousness
the only one we actually knew the whole
time was Trump
for all of his faults
I mean that's interesting but he's the
only one that we kind of knew
most of them like Bill Clinton they just
kind of pop up
he's the governor of a state that nobody
thinks about no offense Arkansas but I
don't think I have any dates there
coming up
so but it's true nobody thought about
Bill Clinton before he became the
president then he became the president
and then we got to know him he likes a
little on the side
he likes a little on the side he likes
little puss
that's what his deal was he wasn't doing
this for his health sure you know he
liked the idea of uh you know people
getting uh some health care and uh
keeping crime low or whatever else he
did in there the welfare reform act but
he liked [__] that's what he did
um I wouldn't know much about Barack
Obama he's cool he played basketball
um he met his wife when they were both
young in law school
and that's all we know about them so
when we find these things out and maybe
he's really not gay maybe he's a little
bi or maybe he was just trying to sound
smart
in that letter by
over-intellectualizing the things he was
saying I don't know
I don't know but I'm not
I'm not mad at that speaking of coming
out variety
uh had their power of young Hollywood
Summit
2023 the power
of young Hollywood
young people in Hollywood
they'd have power
and they're powerful
um
the variety
and it was lovely and The Stranger
Things guy who I respect
the Noah schnapp
which is nicely came out I think he said
he came out because his character was
gay and he said I think that's what he
said which is nice anyway you know
whatever all's well that ends well
but go to his Instagram he keeps making
his face which we have to address and
someone has to get this clip to him
because it this has to stop go to the
left top left he's being honored at
variety close up on the face what is
this
smoldering I don't know what he does
with this all the time be a human being
for a minute like he's always ready to
launch into that face
all of the time and it's almost like is
he getting work done he's 12 years old
but we're honoring him for his long and
storied career and how hard it's been
for him coming out in 2023 but we we you
know we we just we like him we just this
face has to stop
because everything he does he launches
into this
and it's I know it's like the sexy face
but it's like just smile a little bit be
a you know
this other guy was interesting there was
this interview of a guy named Brett
Gelman
Rock
who I don't even understand sometimes
now when young people speak are speaking
and he's being interviewed on the by
this guy Zach sing on the variety red
carpet
and I don't know who all of these uh
people are some of these people were
actors and actresses like Sydney Sweeney
like people that you would know and some
of them were influencers like this guy
Brett Gelman rocker I think that's his
name bretman rock breadman rock Brett
Gelman is a comedian yeah who's Brett
Gelman he's that um he's a kind of like
a character actor all right whatever we
don't need that so this guy Bradman rock
is a Filipino Beauty influencer
and he does this interview with this guy
Zach singing to for the life of me I
don't I can't
fully understand what is transpiring
between both of them I imagine it's a uh
conversation
but it's other red carpet it's like the
craziest thing I've ever heard here it
is there it is
now listen to this now again it's just
I'm trying to understand and decipher
what
is being said here
interview is you you really killed it oh
we ate that [__] up yeah I'm like the
whole world knows how I got circumcised
now thanks to you
girl that was supposed to be a book
exclusive
but it's all over Zack Sang's YouTube
channels with views on and you had the
nerves to put on Tick Tock she wants the
whole world to know so here's well
there's a longer interview and find that
on the on YouTube but
all the people do now when they're in
when they're actually in real life is
just talk about the the internet things
that happen on Tick Tock and no one can
have any type of conversation on one of
these red carpets without it's almost
like people are nervous that they have
to say something that it isn't related
to
some Tick Tock they swatched or some
[__]
video that's out there they just simply
cannot have any conversation uh without
uh mentioning an app
it's it's it's constantly like they're
constantly mentioning an app
uh
and this is so this is some more of this
red carpet interview yeah it was the
full thing which again I'm trying to
decipher
and and understand what has happened at
one point this person starts talking
about chickens here just
uh hello hello hi bretman Rock hi Zach
sang I hear you wanna uh you know you
want to be on the movie screen climax
I'm telling you girl my ass is too fat
for the phone
goes the first guy's interview questions
you want to be on the movie screen you
want to be on the iMac I mean this is
like
this is the interviewer and the first
question is like this guy looks like a a
like an embarrassed guy who just like
showed up and they threw him out on the
red carpet with a microphone
but continue this because it is a
fascinating look into I I just fully
don't understand culture at the moment
IMAX screen to fit in honestly do on the
screens what do I want to do on the
screens just the breadman rock
Shenanigans honestly girl if I if me and
my chickens could walk across that
screen actually let me just pitch my
shot right now Moana I would love to be
the chicken
yeah oh thank you you're my favorite we
you know our last interview is you you
really killed it oh we ate that [__] up
but I'm like the whole world knows how I
got circumcised now thanks to you
this guy came to keep his composure That
was supposed to be a book exclusive
but it's all over Zack Sang's YouTube
channels yeah with views aren't and you
had the nerves to put on Tick Tock I'm
like girl she wants the whole world to
know you look
Joker yes
yes
why tonight why is this look right why
is this the vibe
girl I just wear anything Brian Miller
puts me in my stylist so this he said
this is the vibe and then it's the vibe
and it is
life is good for you life is good
um back home not so much you know with
everything going on in Maui prayers to
Maui yeah
there's nothing better than just the
obligate yes prayers to Maui this no
good I girl if my chickens could get on
the iMac screen prayers to Maui and then
he immediately changed like there's
nothing better than the immediate
reversal where the interviewer was like
no I know it says
it's fine my chickens are fine
thankfully it's on a different Island
um in L.A so no but real talk this is a
real
I have a bunch of um donations and more
information in my YouTube channel not
YouTube channel in my stories not my
YouTube channel go Bret Monroe please
pray for Maui
I love you I'll see you inside this is
the variety young Hollywood power Summit
the power of young Hollywood
pray for Maui uh with with uh
that guy and part of the problem with um
the new generation of actors and
actresses is like uh there some of them
are very talented but
like look at get up that picture of Brad
Pitt and Angelina Jolie and Gwyneth
Paltrow so here's the photo of of Brad
and Gwyneth and it kind of what I like
about this is they they're they're over
it they kind of don't want to be there
it's like they're it's like a Cool vibe
of kind of like [__] you it's a waste of
our time which is again I like that's
what hot you know that's what like a
Hollywood actor actress who in the prime
of their career should be and then
there's just the next photo here where
everybody just seems a little too happy
they're a little too hungry they want it
a little too much except the gentleman
who's in the turtleneck pulled up over
his face I do like that
um but it's just it's they're too happy
and all the people that went to it I was
seeing their Instagrams and they were
all like I'm uh a thank you variety
thank you I'm grateful
thank you for having me I am grateful
for being here and it's like that's not
the energy
that's not the vibe you should have the
vibe is like oh that [__] you know
that's cool go back to
Brad and Gwyneth again this is the vibe
there it is like [__] you this is a
waste of our [__] time not like thank
you variety thank you it means
everything to me it's like no it's a
fake award you got it cause you're hot
just not care
be kind of cool a little bit
you know I was talking with a friend the
other day and he said to me he goes I
think I have to choose between better
hair growth and my health
and I said
no you don't
and he goes I believe that's the choice
I have to make I said
no you don't
I said because neutrophil
provides whole body health approach for
men that promotes healthier hair
and he goes well are there drugs I said
no
and then he said are there compromises
and I said no and he goes what is it
I said just better hair
men think that losing their hair is
inevitable take control of your hair's
future with neutral Falls signs back
hair growth supplement for men did you
know that 80 of men will experience hair
thinning in their lifetime it's normal
but it doesn't have to be your fate
do you get that
like
the concept of Fate is very interesting
because there's people that are
fatalists
who believes that everything happened is
preordained and they lack the ability to
stop it
but then there are people that
understand that life is an adventure a
journey and that you are in the driver's
seat
and in the chaos you can carve out a
path that is uh both uh meaningful and
impactful
and that's I think the best life even
though there is something nice to be
said about fatalism because
you know the Eastern religions and stuff
but what I'm saying is that accepting
things is also good too
you know a friend of mine and his wife
one day she left and just in the car it
was just over and you can't but how do
you ever you know you how do you make
peace with that that's where you got to
be a little
bit of a fatalist but his hair is
weakening and thinning
and I told him
that this worked neutralfold worked in a
clinical study 84 of menstrual
Improvement in their hair after six
months taking neutral full men's hair
growth supplements take the first steps
to visibly thick or healthier hair for
limited time neutral flaws offering
listeners
ten dollars off your first month
subscription and free shipping when you
go to neutrophone.com men and enter the
promo code Tim find out we're over find
out why over 4 000 Healthcare
professionals recommend neutral flow for
healthier hair
neutrifold.com man
neutrophone.com slash man n-u-t-r-a
-f-o-l.com slash men enter the promo
code Tim
that doesn't mean you're gay if you do
that slash man
utraful.com man promo code Tim I've been
fascinated and by the way Australia I've
been fascinated by a story coming out of
Australia and I want to tell the
Australian people uh in no uncertain
terms that I am going to be in your land
in October I'm going to Brisbane I'm
going to Perth I'm going to Melbourne
I'm going to uh Sydney I'm going to
Adelaide I'm even hopping over to New
Zealand and I'm going to uh Christ
church and I'm going to uh the other one
the other place
Auckland
so I'm telling you right now you got to
buy tickets for those at Tim
dilloncomedy.com
I have been fascinated
by this story about a woman who
potentially
poisoned her guests at lunch
with something called the death cap
mushroom
the death cap mushroom I'm not even
going to try to pronounce the scientific
name
but it is native to Eurasia it was
introduced to the United States it is
the sometimes they call it uh destroying
angel or something it is a mushroom that
is the most highly toxic mushroom you
can eat it causes liver failure
um kidney failure all kinds of uh
problems Within
12 to 48 Hours most people that have
ingested this mushroom are dead or dying
and this mushroom looks like other
mushrooms like it has so you base I was
eating a wild mushroom omelet the other
day it's part of my meal plan and I was
going well I hope they this thing's not
in there but this these should never be
like picked and they should have nothing
to do with food uh Amanita
phthalid eyes
I don't know how you would say it
Amanita
whatever it is but the toxin in this
mushroom
is not
killed by uh cooking it
you boiling it it doesn't matter
whatever internal temperature that this
mushroom reaches it does not kill off
any of these toxins okay
so here's the deal
this woman in this town outside of
Melbourne Australia about two hours
south of Melbourne Australia and it's
called Uh liangata and I'm probably
maybe not pronouncing that right
leungatha lianguth leongatha
liangafa whatever it is she has a lunch
okay
she's having a lunch she prepared a meal
that led to
gastrointestinal problems for Gail and
Don Patterson the 70 year old parents of
her ex-husband Gail's sister Heather
Wilkinson 66 and her husband Ian
Wilkinson a 68 year old Pastor in nearby
corombura
were also struck down
the Pattersons and Heather later died at
a hospital while Wilkinson the pastor
fights for his his life at a Melbourne
facility so what she did
and here she is crying she's uh
confronted by the Press
what she did now a fifth person who
attended the lunch was also sickened but
discharged a short time later according
to the times of London
Aaron prepared the deadly dish Beef
Wellington with mushrooms but served a
different meal to herself and her two
young children who were also at the
Gathering she denies wrongdoing this
week telling reporters she cooked a meal
for the best people in her life I can't
believe that this happened and I'm sorry
that they have lost their lives Aaron
said outside her home I didn't do
anything I love them I can't fathom what
happened
so she invites her ex-husband's family
the in-laws
they all come over she makes a beef
wellington pie with death cat mushrooms
the ex-husband invited does not come
[Music]
all of these people are either dead or
dying she eats a different meal with her
children
we don't know where she got the mushroom
she claimed she got him at a local spot
um
we're unsure of where she procured these
mushrooms she's kind of been
you know maybe uh intentionally vague
about that
um the Press is hounding her the
international president showed up
because this is a very number one
if she did it
and I'll tell you why I think she did it
but if she did it this pudgy mom type
from a small town outside of Australia
this woman looks like my aunt
the idea of of cooking for people and
killing them with a poison mushroom in
your own home is so intimate it's so
ghoulish
it's so you know
like
just it's out of a fairy tale right this
is like Hansel and Gretel where they
fatten up the kids to throw them in the
oven it's one of those things where we
we think of poison Foods as like the
poison apple it's a Grimm's Fairy Tale
Sweeney Todd you know putting the people
in the pies
it is something that captures our
imagination
and I think that's why people are
riveted
buy this now here's why I think she did
it because her ex-husband had a
mysterious gastrointestinal problem
her ex-husband Simon Patterson
reportedly spending 16 days in an
induced coma with a mysterious gut
illness last year after eating food
served by her
Simon suspected he had been poisoned by
Aaron A source told the Herald's son
there were times he had felt a bit off
and it coincided
with when he spent time with her I think
she's getting off
poisoning people
and I gotta be honest
I like it
I like it because it's something we
haven't seen
this is a new type of villain
we know about munchausen's by proxy
where the parents make their kids sick
so the parents get all the attention
they keep going to the doctor they keep
making their children sick it's very
heinous
this is kind of interesting
there's this chubby mom
in rural Australia
who's poisoning her like she poisoned
her husband
and he stayed in a coma for 16 days and
he somehow made it out
and she might have just she decided to
poison her entire family with these
mushrooms
Kill Them All
because she never got caught this is why
she never got caught
when she did it to the husband they said
it was a mysterious gut illness
he didn't die
she might have been thinking to herself
maybe they'll all die
but maybe it won't be traced back to me
or maybe it'll all be some mysterious
illness they'll write it off as a weird
pathogen
but they were able to identify the the
the toxin the mushroom
but I think she thought you could just
do this I think she thought you could do
it and get away with it because she had
gotten away with it with the husband I
think she thought I can just poison
people I'll invite them to my home I'll
make them a beef wellington pie which
does sound good and and they'll die and
we'll just assume it was a great tragedy
and we won't be able to link it to the
ingredient that killed them she goes no
one will quite know how they died
because she's probably kind of a simple
tin
even though she's poisoning people she's
probably reading about these mushrooms
online she probably doesn't know about
the diagnostic tools that maybe the
police would have in a situation like
this or what the even though there's DNA
and there's all this stuff you would
think that she'd be smart enough to know
and if she knew she didn't care but I
think maybe she thought she was going to
get away with it now she's crying get
out the video where she's crying
she comes home
the international press has descended on
her home blue chew is a unique online
service that delivers the same active
ingredients as Viagra Cialis and Levitra
but in chewable tablets end at a
fraction of the cost you could take them
anytime day or nights you can plan ahead
or be ready whenever an opportunity
arises the process is simple son of a
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive
prescription within days the best part
it's done online so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
Born in the USA
and prepared and Ship Direct to your
door in a discreet package it works
people love it everyone loves it
um everyone I know takes it and then in
the group chat shows how big their dick
is after taking the blue tube and and
it's it's heterosexual
um
Bluetooth wants to help you have better
sex discover your options at
bluetooth.com chew it and do it and
we've got a special uh deal for our
listeners try Bluetooth free when you
use their promo code TD at checkout just
pay five dollar shipping that's
Bluetooth promo code TD to receive your
first month free visit bluetooth.com for
more details and important safety
information and go and thanks Bluetooth
for sponsoring the podcast look at the
Princess Diana bear you need some blue
true
[Applause]
can you tell us about the meal that you
cooked she doesn't seem that upset
yeah she this is devastated by what's
happened
in hospital you know what this looks
like you know what it reminds me of it's
like a bad audition tape when somebody
when you're looking at self tape and
somebody's auditioning foreign
she's not selling it here
and
it's noticeable
how not upset she is some of the best
people that I've ever met
Gail was like
take your time
that I didn't have because my mum passed
away four years ago and Gail's never
been anything but good and kind to me
he's wiping no tears from her eyes so
some of the best people I've ever met
they never did anything wrong to me and
I'm so devastating
can you tell
them and to the families and to my own
children I've lost their grandmother can
you tell us why you've poisoned them can
you tell us a bit more about the lunch
we started with a salad what I can tell
you
I just can't fathom what has happened ah
I just can't fit them what has happened
yeah you can you can but Ian and Heather
have lost their lives oh that guy has
lost her life and Donna's still in
hospital and I pray I pray I pray that
he pulls through but he won because my
children love him yeah can you tell us
about the lunch I can't fathom what
happened I'm devastated I love them
and I can't believe that this has
happened and I'm so sorry
that they have lost their lives
I can't believe it
she killed them she did it okay that's
where the mushrooms came from
goodbye
when the subject of the mushrooms came
which by the way would have been my
first question
that would have been question number one
while she's standing there giving this
horrible performance about how much she
cared about everybody how about go okay
thank you put a pin in that uh the
mushrooms where did you get the
mushrooms first question only question
but let's watch her now she runs into
her eyes in the car yeah house or she
gets in the car now
now she's getting in the car
she's going to the grocery store she's
got to get a lot more mushroom for all
the Press she's got to get everybody
mushrooms
wouldn't it be great if she came out
with pies for everybody
come here and have some boys I've made
lunch
do you have anything to say about that I
say I didn't do anything I loved them
I'm devastated that they're gone and I
hope
come on in let me show you how much
y'all can I made I've made pudding and
boys come in
she likes it man she's got a Dark Inner
life she's got a Dark Inner life where
she's poisoning her family she that's
what she's about this lady
unless I'm wrong and then this is a
horrible character assassination but I
doubt I am I doubt I am and you know it
as well
she doesn't care she's not that upset
she walks away when they ask about the
mushrooms she knows she poisoned these
people I don't know why she did it but
there's something amazing about it
they're all eating she's watching them
eat she knows it's the end
and she's just sitting there with her
kids I understand why you'd serve the
kids a separate meal there's [__] no
reason in the world that she didn't try
what she made
she didn't even try it those mushrooms
are fatal not even at high doses now
obviously some of the mushrooms are more
toxic than others I was reading about
that you know the doses in them are not
always consistent
because there was a guy that ate them
and then survived but this woman were to
expect that she did not try the food she
was eating
there's no way
she could know why the why would you
kill everybody
why would you kill
that's the one thing that I'm hung up on
here and I don't quite have an answer
for I don't quite have an answer
for why she would kill but she wanted to
get them all she had the ex-husband she
wanted to kill everybody the ex-husband
his parents and their in-laws she wanted
to kill them all poison everybody and I
don't quite know why
she might just get off on she tried to
kill the husband once we know that
wouldn't it be funny if it comes out
tomorrow that like it was just a tainted
batch of mushrooms from uh you know like
the Farm Stand and [__] no it's not
these mushrooms don't accidentally end
up
this is something that
one thousand percent was a premeditated
hit
and she wanted everybody she wanted the
husband
and we talked about this thing on the
patreon where a guy shoots his wife it's
not a true crime podcast right now but
it's the summer and people act up this
is what happens in the summer it gets
hot out people act up people this guy in
Orange County shot his wife we talked
about that on the patreon this woman
poisoned her family people start when it
gets hot out people get wacky and people
start doing crazy things
I get it
this is it's such a fascinating story to
me
I want to know how they're going to
prove it if they're going to get like if
they're gonna arrest her if they're
gonna formally charge her if they're
going to be able to link this
they got to figure out where she got
these mushrooms but
it is Australia so I don't exactly know
the steps that would be different from
had this happened in uh America but
this sort of thing doesn't happen here
one lingatha resident told the newspaper
Monday
but this wasn't the first time her
cookie made someone sick and then they
talk about the husband
he wrote about the element on Facebook
listen to what this guy wrote
I collapsed at home then was in an
induced coma for 16 days through which I
had three Emergency Operations mainly on
my small intestine plus an additional
planned operation he reportedly wrote my
family were asked to come and say
goodbye to me twice as I was not
expected to live
can you imagine this chubby [__] going
in there twice
and then it's still the and then he
still comes back
Patterson suspected his unforeseen
illness had been linked to eating
nightshades a family of plants that
includes Tomatoes potatoes and peppers
all night shade vegetables contain
alkaloids like solanine a chemical that
can be toxic in high concentrations
but how much [__] eggplant are you
eating
there's no way she's doing this
this is a new archetype of murderer a
kind of cuddly you know she looks like a
koala bear and she's just poisoning
people with natural poisons through food
because if you use an agent that's a
chemical agent that's easily
identifiable you can get caught what
she's doing
which is very interesting
is she is going out and finding things
where
they are highly toxic in the right dose
and trying to get people and I just
don't know what snapped in her head why
she wanted to do everybody at once why
not one at a time but she might have
figured she might have said I may get
caught for this one I got to do them all
I got to do them all I got to get my
husband his family and there's more to
this story than what we're knowing
there's something there's something else
going on here and it it's been keeping
me up at nights I want to talk to this
woman I want her on my show by the way
lizzo they're not letting her they're
taking out of taking her out of
contention for the Super Bowl halftime
show
they're not letting her be and you know
who's doing it now Dylan Mulvaney and
she's doing and this is what's really
offensive she's doing lizzo songs with
the fat black dancers
so Dylan Mulvaney's gonna go and go why
a man great till he got a big and with
the fat black that's not right
but this woman in Australia I
I want to talk to her the crocodile
tears are fake it's this is she did this
and I want to know why she wanted to get
and she's been [__] around for a
while poisoning people
it's got to be so interesting to make a
meal and try to kill someone with it
it really is
kind of a ghoulish
thing and like is it wrong for me to say
that I kind of like
I kind of am interested in this woman a
little bit like I want to know about her
she obviously has some real problems
but to me she's more interesting than
anybody at the variety of young
Hollywood power Summit she's not more
attractive but she is more interesting
to me because people that deal in uh
poisons like that and will kill a bunch
of people with a pie
for example
are some of the most they're just
villainous in a way that's truly
terrifying and Suburban you know all
these Suburban villains the Gilgo Beach
killer this [__] this is the summer of
the suburbs you know we all expected
there to be a lot of crime in the cities
this summer and I'm sure uh people
getting thrown in front of trains and
people getting beheaded but I don't have
the time to go on the NYPD blotter and
look all the time but that always
happens gunshots always you know rise
but this summer The truly interesting
cases have been of like kind of like
Suburban Pool and Patio types having
these Dark Inner lives and killing
people and it's very very uh fascinating
to me these are always the ones that get
you
it's the guy or the mom in their
mid-size crossover hybrid SUV they go
into a gas station they buy a [__]
bottle of water you stand right next to
them maybe you work in the same building
as them you see them uh online at uh the
grocery store and you think nothing of
it but
they can only get off by killing people
or thinking about killing peace she
probably thought about this day in and
day out until she actually made it
happen
and I I wanna I want them to never
obviously she did the wrong thing but I
also want them to be like
I want this to unravel a little bit I
wanna
because you know she's probably tried
this a bunch of times or probably didn't
work she probably tried it with other
things
how great would it be if she tried to
kill like right comp but his stomach was
too strong
this is actually good listen to me this
is fine I enjoyed this
it would be amazing if it didn't affect
anyone
but it it it it killed everyone so we're
going to keep tabs on that story
uh when I'm in Australia if there was
any way for me to meet this woman not
eat with her but if there's any way for
me to meet her I'd love to meet her
I'd love to talk with her I'd love to
have her on my show I'm a sympathetic
hearer I do understand
I love uh cooking I love the hospitality
I love dinner parties I understand
things go left it's not always your
fault
um I have a lot of empathy for her I've
entertained and not everything is the
way I'd want it to be so to someone like
this I say like I get it and I'm a
sympathetic ear to you I want to know
why you did it I
want to hear about why uh you did it I
love Morgan and Morgan
it's it's a law firm but they help
and they only make money if you win
I'll tell you about a car accident I was
in and you'll tell me
how how awesome it was that I found
Morgan and Morgan
one time I was driving my car
I was driving it ten and two you know I
was doing everything right I was sober
and I was driving my car
driving it down the road listening to
that song I got money in the bank shorty
what you drank a long time ago
and
I was hit
not good
as I was driving straight
a woman
hit my car
because she was not paying attention
and I was like I had an injury
I had an injury
and I was very
I was in a lot of pain and I was
confused disoriented and angry sad
scared alone
and I was feeling hopeless because I'm
like I wish there was an uh personal
injury Law Firm
that would take this case
but I said it's it's got to be so hard
but then the reality was I found Morgan
and Morgan and submitting an injury
claim with Morgan Morgan is so easy
it's more like using an app than hiring
a lawyer submitting a claim to Morgan
and Mormon more submitting a claim to
Morgan Morgan
is as easy as pie
submitting a claim to Morgan and Morgan
is as easy as pretending you don't see
the 5 PM email from your boss
with Morgan and Morgan submitting uh
claim is as easy as hitting snooze on
your alarm for the eighth time
submitting a claim to Morgan and Morgan
is as easy as swiping right on
a dating app
submitting a claim to Morgan and Morgan
is as easy as watching the planes flying
in the towers and then accepting the
official narrative and going to war in
two countries for 20 years
now which one
didn't
they write
if you're ever injured you could check
out Morgan and Morgan their fee is free
unless you win and they win which means
you win for more information go to
forthepeople.com or dial pound law pound
529 from your cell phone that's or the
Obama phone that you got the free one
that's for the people.com Tim or pound
law pound29 from your shell this is a
paid advertisement so something that's
going on this summer which I do not
support is salt and straw the ice cream
place from Portland which is partially
owned by Dwayne The Rock Johnson has
lost their [__] mind these are some
of their flavors this summer chocolate
potato salad
spiced mustard ice cream potato chip
cookies fudge what the [__] is going on
Dwayne Johnson and the [__] lesbian
wiccans that own salt and straw baked
brie and fig cheesecake free cheesecake
ice cream candied Rich crackers thick
fig Jam what's happening
cinnamon and honey Fried Chicken served
by whites
spiced vanilla ice cream bits of fried
chicken croissant
so I now here at the Timberland show I'm
gonna try these flavors
um
and then I'm going to unalive myself
right afterwards as a protest because
Dwayne The Rock Johnson doesn't he have
enough [__] money
someone get to him and tell him that
this is crap
I'm going to try these ice creams
because they're insane salt and straw is
always doing [__] like this like they
have olive oil flavor like olive oil and
goat cheese ice cream it annoys
everybody and it's wrong we've got 75
000 homeless people here now and I think
it's a little weird to have basil ice
cream and you know all that [__]
so the first one I'm trying is uh
chocolate potato
uh salad and this is the mustard
flavored ice cream which I think is
probably heinous now it would be a great
bit if I ate four pints like if I every
single pint I just ate the entire Pie as
I was talking about how gross it is I
was like this is horrible but I am going
to try this now I don't know why you
would even make this kind of ice cream
this is mustard flavored ice cream with
fudge and potato chips in it
Malcolm was not good
a knockoff that's not good
this is if you're listening to this this
is a visual gag
that was not good
I know that we were thinking like maybe
it would be good
not good now we're going to try cinnamon
and honey Fried Chicken
I don't know if this is going to be good
or not but
again not really
I gotta be honest
not really
they're just [__] up over there it's
knock up
not terrible
baked brie and fig cheesecake
again it's just awe it's something's
wrong
something is wrong it's just not it's
truly not great like you can try all
these I have people in the studio you
can all try them
they're not that they're not that good
um they're they're not good
and then the last one is sour cherry pie
I imagine this is good or some type of
good
but who knows because salt and straw has
been [__] up a long time because
Dwayne The Rock Johnson
you know
it's too busy endorsing uh Kamala Harris
and what he's not doing is his mind's
not on his business
that's not bad
um
no the sour cherry pie is good
my mother has passed away uh this is uh
something we should say and I should say
it
um uh while uh after I eat the ice cream
and it's very sad it was you know
obviously
um it's uh it's very new it's a new
development
um but she was suffering at the end of
her life and it's it's it's it's hard
when someone's suffering I've talked
about it multiple times
um we're cremated I'm not choking up I'm
coughing on the mustard [__] ice
cream it's literally heinous it's
heinous
18 is
um we're cremating her because that's
what she wanted
um and and we're and I I and she we're
scattering her ashes
and
she loved Hawaii
this is a fact she went to Hawaii as a
young person all the time
I'm asking a question I'm asking a
question now I'm asking a question I
don't know if this is the case
is it bad taste
if I go to Maui
with an urn of my mother's ashes
and scatter them in the ash
that is is that wrong
or is it beautiful
is it actually beautiful
oral are the people going to get mad at
me if I do that I mean serious question
are the people
going to get mad at me because
apparently their tragedy is the only
tragedy we have to think about right now
right
but I think if I went there with ashes
and I would say that to them I would say
I'm here with my mother's ashes in
Maui
and I'm here to just
I'm here you know and they're gonna and
I'm not here to help
and I I'm glad there are people that are
there to help but I'm not there to help
because I got my own thing
I got my own thing and I imagine the
Four Seasons is unaffected this is what
we've Googled and I would stay there of
course but I and I just want to know is
that a bad look
if I go
to Four Seasons with my mother's
measures I don't know
uh [__] salt and straw stop doing this
with the summer flavors they are heinous
you know they're not good the sour
cherry pie is good but everything else
everything else is bad
timberlandcomedy.com on patreon we have
an amazing episode this week
um and I'm all over the place uh come
see me live timlecomedy.com to grab
tickets thank you and good night